hi everyone my name is tupaz and today
we will explore a topic that is really
relevant in applied research and that's
the interrelations between our Target
labels in the actual real world and this
question will take us on a path from
classical categorical classification all
the way to regression so today we will
see how acknowledging the inner
relations of our Target labels can boost
the knowledge in our training phase a
better model the world and improve
robustness
so what's on our agenda we will start
with categorical classification and some
hidden assumptions that you need to
revisit in order to understand if this
approach really serves your learning
task best we will then overview
different approaches to utilize your
discrete categorical labels and in this
talk my focus is on deep learning neural
network based methods but many of them
are adaptable to other machine learning
techniques but since this is a short
talk I will just give a brief overview
and highlight the main Concepts
uh in the third part our discrete
categories will meet the continuous
world and we will discuss how to
leverage them and lastly I will give a
short cookbooks of tips and a decision
diagram for you to follow when
considering a new task of what seems to
be at first glance as categorical
classification
so let's start
considering a task in which you are
given an image and are being asked is a
lion an elephant or a giraffe when
looking at it we do not find ourselves
considering the relations between them
in order to make that decision is that
giraffe closer to be an elephant or a
lion this question is irrelevant in this
case because since those categories are
independent in the context of the input
data that we are provided with
so this is a straightforward nominal
categorical classification problem
but if we'll stop to think about it we
realize that many of the categorizations
tasks around us actually have a relation
between the target categories they have
an order so if it's product rating and
recommendation How likely is an offer to
be the best fit for a specific user if
it's age prediction in order to adapt
user content and offerings or medical
diagnosis so especially in such cases
some mistakes have dire consequences
compared to others so misclassifying
severe medical stage with a good health
stage obviously
um does not have the same consequences
as misclassifying severe diagnosis with
very severe stage so we want our
learning to be cost sensitive because
sum is classifications have greater
risks than others
let's start with the basics and
understand its limitation nominal or
classical categorical classification
be alarmed this part of the talk has
formulas but so bear with me and the
following chapters after this one will
be almost equations free
um so from now on let's assume we are
given measurements the X measurements
and are being asked sorry to predict the
weather for the next day would it be
cloudy sunny and hot or Stormy Weather
so we have discrete targets cloudy Sunny
rainy and we output prediction the
prediction that tries to describe the
probability of each option given an
input measurement X
so if we use softmax as our last
activation layer we will get prediction
where each entry is between 0 to 1 and
the entire Vector sums into one so
basically by doing that we assume that
our categories are mutually exclusive
and assume that in the training process
we have specific sample where when the
measurements were taken it was indeed
Sunny for the next day so the true label
for this specific measurement X is sunny
so I highlighted here uh that one in
yellow
and we predicted this output vector we
predicted 64 percent of it being sunny
when it actually was sunny
so how do we encode the true category
for our training process well the most
common way is to use one hot vectors
where only the entry of the true class
is labeled as one and the rest are zeros
so when the training process will
converge it will try to mimic that one
holding coding and what it will do is
basically have just one dominant class
the one that's labeled here at one and
all the rest will be pushed to zero so
it's like pushing all the other classes
infinitely away from the true class and
this may be desirable when the classes
are independent however it may also lead
to overconfidence
but uh given that prediction how do we
measure how well are we because uh we
actually asked the network to learn that
this should be a 100 prediction not only
64. so the most common categorical loss
is the cross entropy loss which I'm sure
many of you probably use many times now
let's take a deeper look
when we use one hot labels where only
the entry of the true class is set to 1
and the rest are zeros we can see that
the contribution of a specific sample to
the cross-entropy loss only takes into
account the true the true label the true
class because all other entries are zero
so we'll only have penalty for the 64
compared to 100 right here it doesn't
care that we predicted 28 cloudy eight
percent rainy only that's the 64 is
still far from 100. so basically what it
does it balances the true positives over
false negatives of this true class and
that's it
um so and one more thing it standalizes
false negative
of the same class of different classes
the same way so if we have a false
negative rain prediction meaning that we
missed the rain prediction it will have
same penalty as me as missing uh true
cloudy prediction
but some misdetections have higher risk
than others so let's say the
implications of missing a rainy day are
more costly sorry than missing a cloudy
day prediction
so let's consider here that this is one
alternative for prediction and this is
the other so basically for the true
class both of them have 64 prediction of
the true class but I switched here the
order between the Alternatives so before
we it was eight percent rain but now
it's it's
28 rain
well one alternative be has uh have a
different effect on our loss compared to
the other
well basically using the cross entropy
with 100 vectors then no only this the
the middle one right here will have an
influence
so basically we want uh we know that
some misclassifications
are uh worse than others so it's not
only the type of class we missed to
detect that we care about it's what we
mistaken it for that we should care
about as well
so we want our learning to be cost
sensitive
so mainly we want to a panelize
misdetections false negatives
differently for each class B we want to
post we also want to penalize false
positives not only the balance of true
positives and false negatives and see
there are cases where some false
positives should have greater risks than
other
so those two papers suggest adjustments
for the cross Center for pillows in
order to address it one is the bilinear
cross entropy and the second one is the
real world cross entropy so the first
term right here uh you are familiar with
that one it's the class weighted cross
entropy especially popular in unbalanced
classification problems each type of
false negative gets its own class weight
but what about false positives
the the laws of misclassifying rainy as
Sunny hot Remains the Same as
misclassifying sunny as cloudy
so the second term Waits differently
different types of false positives it
described the cost of misclassifying the
true Class C tag as Class C
and the same but in victorial form we
see that the first term has W Matrix
which is diagonal you are familiar with
that as a vector of the class weights
that is the input for the weighted cross
entropy loss and the second term
the a matrix is has off diagonal
elements each of them is the risk of a
different type of false positive
different type of misclassification so
back to our example if those are the
true classes and those are the
predictions we can now have different
risks for different
misdetection so for example if the true
class was rain but we said it's sunny we
could we can give it a higher risk than
the others
so and know that it doesn't have to be
symmetrical because if we predicted sun
and in fact it was rainy then people
will be outside without umbrellas
getting all wet they will be mad at us
but if we said that it it's going to
rain but eventually it was sunny then
everyone's surprised for the best and no
harm is done so it doesn't have to be
symmetrical
so the weather categories task is just
one example in many other real world
applications order matters
now that we cover the assumptions and
limitations of basic categorical
classification we move on to ordinal
regression
um so basically uh throughout this
chapter I will return to the following
example as soon we get an image or
measurement of a plan and we need to
estimate its level of stress
is it experiencing uh some stress based
on for example insufficient watering so
we want to know that in order to for
example adapt irrigation or something
like that so we have categories we have
the no stress category moderate stress
and complete stress basically that plant
is gone and as in many categories that
describe a process through time we can
observe that those are ordered
categories
now let's consider what may happen when
ignoring that order and addressing it as
a regular categorical classification
problem we may end up with the following
confusion metrics so the y-axis here are
the true classes
and X are their predictions so we can
see that in uh in the mild cases the
true mild cases in 30 of the time we
predict the dose is severe not even
moderate severe so this is really far
away from the true class if we are to
make a mistake in 30 of the time so at
least let it be with the Json class for
example
um instead of Miles say it's moderate
and we can see another such example here
twenty percent of the severe cases were
predicted as no stress so basically we
want to push those toward the main
diagonal and if we will observe the
feature space that illustration right
here
um we can see that since we did not
provide any constraint regarding the
order
then especially in cases where we have
lower amounts of data we may end up with
sub-optimal cluster relations so for
example the no stress cluster right here
it came up to be closer to the severe
than it is to the moderate
well fear not regression comes to our
rescue
so ordinal regression let's look at some
example where we have ordered categories
so for example a teenager for age
categories is older than a kid
an adult is also older than a kid but is
also older than a teenager and so on so
we want to really encode that order into
our learning process
um ordinal regression in neural networks
was introduced in the NN rank paper
basically uh the basic concept behind it
was uh to represent the order of the
categories through our labels so instead
of using one hot Vector where only the
true class index is marked in one and
the rest are zeros
it is suggested in a different approach
where for class K the Kate index and
everything before it is set 1 and the
rest to zero so basically uh what it
does it encodes a distance between those
classes
and we can notice that the Assumption of
classes being mutually exclusive no
longer holds so basically we cannot use
the soft Max we'll use the sigmoid
instead
um so the labeled vectors now have
meaning to the distances between them
let's revisit uh the same classification
problem so earlier we use that as a
nominal classification we got those uh
far away from diagonal values and
sub-optimal cluster cluster order in the
feature space let's revisit that when we
use ordinal regression we now may get
that confusion Matrix with values being
much more closer to the main diagonal so
basically even if the recall of each
class Remains the Same and the total
amount of um of forces Remains the Same
the entire risk here is lower because
the nature of the mistakes is better and
if we will examine the feature space we
will see that order between those
clusters their nearest neighbors nearest
neighboring clusters now make more sense
and many architectures designed to solve
the ordinal regression for K classes
model the problem using K minus 1 binary
classifiers so as we mentioned before an
adult is older than a kid but also older
than a teen so each binary classifier
divides the world into two possibilities
above or below the category K so for the
plant example each classifier will
output the probability of the condition
being a Graver than a specific stress
level so for example one binary
classifier will model the probability of
the stress level of the plant to be
above none another classifier will will
have the probability of the stress level
to be above mild and so on and so on and
the reason we only need K minus 1
classifiers is that if the K minus 1
classifier have stress level to be above
severe
if that probability is above the
threshold that means that we are in the
last category which is the category
above severe tests it's decade category
the complete category
um so uh looking at the following
example of output predictions that are
above the uh the half threshold we get
the condition
that for example the stress level to be
above moderate past that condition so it
is likely that the stress level is above
moderate but
we also got that the probability of the
stress to be above mild is lower than
threshold but obviously that does not
make sense because those categories are
ordered everything above moderates is by
definition also above mild so this is a
contradiction this contradiction is
called
um ranking consistency basically we had
no constraints between those binary
classifiers
um so because what we desire we desire
for this monotonous Behavior right here
to solve that crawl paper suggests
weight training of the output nodes
where they only differ in their biases
so basically it enforces the consistency
while it's it managed to solve the
consistency problem it also introduces a
strict limitation the weight sharing and
that really limits the network capacity
later on in the corn paper they reduced
the weight sharing limitation by
introducing
um basically the chain Rule and
introducing the conditional probability
training sets
but in the next chapter of our talk we
will see beyond the available course
labels
for this example let's look on age
prediction assume that I present you
with a picture of this woman and I ask
you to estimate an absolute value
what is her exact age
even though this is not an unfamiliar
data domain for us as human annotators
this may still be a difficult task now
let's assume that for this data set I
have course categorical labels so I'll
provide you with the following prior
this woman belongs to age category 30 to
40.
so basically I'm asking you drop the
cursor at this exact location in that
segment right here
um so this task is still hard because as
humans we make better precise decision
when being asked relative
question when we compare Alternatives
and not being asked to give one absolute
answer and this methodology in decision
making is called analytic hierarchy
so the moving window ordinal regression
from the last cvpr leverages this
concept into the training and inference
decision making so suppose instead of
giving you the prior of the course Edge
category let's say I have age
information for a subset so I present
you with two examples that bound that
woman age from both sides so this woman
is older than that 31 year old
and she's also younger than that 38 year
old
now I ask you how old is she you are now
able to compare and make a prediction
and repeat in an iterative sort like
algorithm way
so far we talked about discrete
categories while ordered but yet
discrete but the world is continuous
it's just our mind that is discrete
so we used earlier the example of the
plant experiences stages of stress you
can see now that those images were taken
from a great time lapse video created by
Adam Chomsky he filmed that process
through five days okay so as humans we
tend to categorize in order to just
simplify our world
but as a discrete output for a
continuous world really serves us
optimally do we want our machines to
mimic our limited labeling capabilities
or we wish they will outperform us
so especially in cases where human
expert opinions required and humans are
asked to categorize into final
resolution in those scenarios humans
tend to lose objectiveness of the
categorization task final resolution is
really hard to do
and and also humans May tend to change
their choices when being presented with
the same samples again based on for
example the order of previous samples
that they saw
so in many cases what we will really
have are only course labels course
categories but the world is continuous
so some samples do not distinctly belong
to just one category as we saw for the
plant stress level now say that we have
one category for teenagers
um let's say it's up to 18 age
and the second category for young adults
starting from 19 year olds
so an 18 year old do not distinctly
belong to one of those categories more
than to the other
so this introduces us a concept from
classical clustering fuzzy class
membership
where a sample has partial membership to
more than just one class
now let's consider the scatter of the
following clusters
we do not want to force a hard label on
the samples that are here between those
two clusters
we want to encode membership to more
than just one class for example using
the distance of the samples from each of
the cluster centers
as described right here
and the distance really it could be
euclidean or it could be exponential
distance and then we'll get a soft Max
like form
and we can see that the the sum of all
class memberships of the sample J sum
into one
and also so basically what we'll have
here instead of one holding coding we'll
get categorical memberships
those soft labels
fuzzy membership to each of those
classes
for example based on the distances as we
said and hinton's paper from uh
2019 described an additional benefits of
using soft over integer discrete labels
and that was shown to improve
calibration of the network and also to
reduce the overconfidence but what I
really love about this approach is that
it introduces the relations between our
classes by only changing the way we
encode the labels so no special
architecture no K minus one binary
classifiers just plug and play
and the approach we saw earlier still
assumes course Target categories
so we have k categories however we can
also encode a categorical membership
Vector into a single real number so
instead of K labels we get just this one
point a point between the course
categories we can do that for example by
using a weighted average of the
categorical membership
so basically the categorical membership
will be the weights and we multiply them
by the for example class number or if we
want that to be between zero to one then
we can use uniform steps between 0 to 1
to describe the the centers of the
Clusters so we get one number
basically by basically when we do that
we no longer assume we only have k
categories that are important because we
know the world is actually continuous
and choosing K is therefore arbitrary so
basically we're moving from discrete
labels distribution into a continuous
one
having real numbers as targets we may
use now linear regression this will
results in clusters being like
continuously spread uh through the axis
that connects the cluster centers that
axis describe the order of the classes
their orthogonal axis is then expected
to condense
but wait why should we prefer overlap
instead of increasing the margin well
that's because in our case
the margin does not really exist there
is no clear cut so we do not want to
force the network to create a margin
between an 18 year old and a 19 year old
while we predict age groups because it
may force it to overfit on irrelevant
features
and when we wish to make sure that we
generalized well we want to look on
feature space and see that the order of
our course categories clusters makes
sense now but not only that we want to
if for example we have specific smaller
test set where we have finer grained
labels for example specific ages for
this smaller subset then we want to dive
in inside each cluster and see inside
the cluster the order and see that we
generalized well
check how well we generalized see that
it makes sense
but we will not always have a large
number of categories in cementation task
it will not be feasible to annotate into
more than say five categories in such
cases when we try to restore labels
distribution from those course ones we
will get locations where we'll have
values like the one right here
those values do not really exist in
those areas we Face unbalanced
regression problem
while unbalanced classification is a
subject of great research and one's
regression on the other hand in deep
neural network has room for new progress
in recent cvpr the balanced MSE was
introduced in order to address the
imbalance in deep regression
in the last concluding two slides I will
summarize the take-home message
so when facing a new task that seems
like classification start from the
ground up
get to know your data what labels can
you expect to have course categorical
or can you be provided with a subset of
continuous related measurements
is an expert human opinion required for
the training process and what will be
the optimal format and labeling strategy
to achieve it
also talk to your domain expert find out
what are the relations between your
target classes what is the cost of each
type of misclassification what other
prior assumptions can you make and on
top of that question the format of the
requested output for example let's say
you are being asked to predict if a
student will fail pass or excel in an
exam what will benefit the specific
business goal better a discrete answer
or a number between 0 to 1.
so to summarize the following diagram
can help guide you with your
architecture strategy
so we want to ask ourselves are your
target categories ordered if so is a
continuous output more desirable
or are some categories less distance
from from their nearest neighbors than
others in those cases you may prefer
soft labels or linear regression over
hard ordinal categorization I hope this
talk will success successful in
demonstrating the considerations when
we're facing what may seem at first
glance as straightforward classification
and especially how understanding the
relation of your labels May leverage
your use of them
um thank you so much feel free to reach
out via LinkedIn I will be happy to
continue our discussion and get your
feedback about your talk and if you want
to read more about the topic you can
find it in my blog thank you so much
no thank you topaz
yeah we just have Jeremy asking about
if your slides are available and
suggestions on where to learn more
uh yeah well my slides are not yet
available but you can find more
information in my blog post about it